welcome to our second show thank you
last night was our first and we healed a
nation I believe not America we healed
France France has been reunified by our
show yeah yeah you know it's funny I was
very interested to find out what people
thought about some of art the changes
sure that we've made you know your and
so I go online I'm looking and a lot of
nice things were said the biggest thing
that people were commenting on my
wardrobe yeah it well I mean it was a
constant for 25 years 25 years I was in
a suit and the comment I kept seeing
over and over again is Conan looks
relaxed now now I've been doing this
show for 25 years and everybody in
America thought I looked like an uptight
[ __ ] and not one of you said anything
nobody after I knew it you know what I
mean four years old he looks like an
accountant this is they like that they
like that I mean tonight the look I'm
going for is farmer applying for a loan
I'd like to buy a new digger for the
back 40 this is my hat by the way that
I'm holding who thought I was turning a
very small steering wheel anybody yeah
did you get that bad and I thought the
bank was in a boat I'm gonna keep going
more and more relaxed every night
tomorrow night I'm gonna wear a footy
pajamas out here next week a speedo and
Crocs
look at this guy this guy's like bring
on the speedo and crops
you're freakin MIT why are you no stop
it no hands this guy's been thrown out
of more strip clubs what listen you put
a buffet in front of him he's gonna
sample yeah you're right you're right